our first speaker of today is dr mike
osley
he's an agronomist with north dakota
state university carrington research
extension center
dr mike gosley is the research
agronomist
his research includes a broad range of
topics including crop and livestock
integration
cover crop and herbicide interactions
variety testing weed management and
precision agriculture also round out his
experience i grew up near northwood
north dakota on a diversified drop in
chief operation and then also dr audra
calall she was she is our host of the
meeting today
she is the plant pathologist here at the
north dakota state university um
williston research extension center she
attained her bs in biology from the
university of minnesota in 2007 and
worked in the commercial inoculant
industry for three years prior to
entering her graduate program
audrey obtained her phd in plant
pathology from the university of
wisconsin-madison where she studied
nodulating bacteria and mycorrhizal
fungal
audrey currently leads an applied
research program focused on management
of plant disease in durham peas lentils
chickpeas and sugar beet as well as
nodulation and nitrogen fixation in
chickpeas
audrey currently co-leads the north
central ipm center
pulse crop working group and initiated
and oversee and oversees the growing
pulse crops podcast series
then dr claire keane she's joining us
online
she is an assistant professor at north
dakota state university
she earned her phd in agronomy from penn
state university from 2016 to 2021 she
was the extension specialist in cropping
systems here at the williston research
extension center
while in williston claire worked with
local producers answering questions
about weed control
saline soil reclamation organic
transition and alternative cropping and
marketing practices
she also conducted research on chickpea
flax intercropping salt tolerant alfalfa
varieties and the new perennial small
grain kerns up
in july of 2021 claire joined the ndsu
department of plant sciences in fargo as
an assistant professor of small grain
and corn agronomy so welcome all three
of our
speakers this morning
okay thanks
so i'm gonna kind of kick things off
here and um really before we get into
the the meats of the
chickpea flax i'm gonna go over a little
bit of uh
an overview uh just to of what we're
saying when we're talking about
intercropping and then just some of the
basic concepts
uh behind it
so
for instance here we're talking about
chickpea flax
this here's a picture i took right off
the combine
so you can see
i think this is a combination that
actually threshes out really well when
they're combined together
they've got a few
green foxtail in this particular sample
but overall other than that really nice
clean samples so what we're talking
about
uh when we say inner cropping meaning
we're gonna plants
and harvest
two crops or more
at the same time so
we're not talking about making extra
passes across the field during the
growing season
but we are usually talking about
separating the harvested grain out after
harvest in almost all cases okay
so one extra step usually after harvest
but hopefully no extra steps during the
growing season compared to growing a
single crop
right and so
uh this is generally something that can
be used um
to as a way to increase
space efficiency
uh so
um i think particularly if somebody has
a limited number of acres uh this might
be particularly appealing because you
can make better use of of each acre
and just a few things to note that
some a lot of times you might have a
lower cost of production
simply because there aren't as many
options as you have with one prop
uh because when you start talking about
pest management programs uh oftentimes
you don't have that many options and so
on a necessity
even
even if you plan on doing things
uh cheaper because of some synergies you
might see you might actually be forced
into lower cost of production as well
and then
when we're doing this we do really need
to also try to pair our maturities of
our crops
to make the best use of the
reducing number of operations in the
field
okay
so here's a few pictures
from the carrington research center of
this particular combination of the
chickpea flax we don't have the ability
to alternate rows
on the equipment we have
so there's a lot of debates right off
the bat on whether it's best to
alternate rows or go same rural on
everything right and i think there's
some advantages disadvantages
to either but
uh first and foremost
uh what we need to determine is what our
equipment capabilities are right and so
our equipment is not capable of
alternating rows so we put everything in
the same pearl
uh and it's worked pretty well for us
uh we have our uh
black salon our chickpeas alone
and then here you can see we have a
pretty nice flat stand and if you look
down the rows you'll be able to see all
these little chickpea plants growing
underneath
very healthily
the one thing
that um
i i really noticed in particular in 2020
when we were doing this trial
so if you look down the rows looking at
trying to find all the chickpeas down
here in the plaques
uh we also saw
all right what's the one big weakness on
on flax weed management or at least for
us
uh
so you can use sulfentrazone ahead of
plaques which is excellent
but the one big weakness of
sulfentrazone is pigweeds right and so
we almost always have pigweeds in our
flax crop
all right that's not too bad right here
we use sulfentrazone in this combination
uh you can see a few uh pigweeds popping
up here of where the chickpeas are okay
but the thing i really noticed is when
we had the chickpeas and the flax
growing together
we actually saw
a very noticeable
reduction in the in the
size and stature of the pigweeds that
we're growing in here as well so
uh
definitely wanted to point that out as
even though we do have maybe
reduced options for herbicides
when we're doing mixed combinations we
actually can see
an added benefit of biological weed
suppression right
all right so
a few other notes here
so
i just want to point out that normally i
do these presentations in a standard
agronomy meeting
people aren't really
necessarily looking to do something new
and so i really try to pair people's
expectations down because i think
there's a lot of potential
but with inner cropping but
there are definitely some things we need
to think about before i really encourage
people to go down this route so
number one this trade-off here
i
can over-yielding
by having two crops growing together
uh make up for the cost of separating
grain and the cost of potentially two
different seed lots okay
so that's one of the first things we
need to consider
very likely we will be needing to
desiccate more so than if we had each
crop alone that's not always the case
but i would say there's an increased
chance that we're going to have to
either desiccate or swap
okay we have
less pest management options
okay and then some of the ones that are
labeled for multiple crops in our
systems are usually not quite as
effective
as the best ones you can use for either
crop alone but as i mentioned
sometimes the as long as you can keep it
clean
in the beginning
uh usually the late season weed control
is better
by by the biological weed suppression
right uh and then it also takes time
to perfect a new system
i definitely do not tell people to go in
and plant a hundred acres your first
year uh this is something where we'd say
uh maybe try five or ten acres see what
you think
see how it works for you
right because this is not
simplifying anything right by doing this
we're trying to get more production but
we're making it more complicated and we
need to figure some things out it's
going to look different from farm to
farm
right
and then also there's other basic
management things we need to figure out
too such as
uh you know do we have to add fertilizer
if we have a legume partner in our mix
all right so uh there's a lot of things
that we're still trying to figure out
uh and a lot of things that
you need to figure out doing this on a
farm as well
okay
um
i think this one
might have been outdoors but okay
so
just to give you an example uh one of
the basic concepts
i think in in intercropping it's not the
only thing right but one of the major
things that we
probably will all talk about at some
point today is this concept of over
yielding all right
and
for those that need to calculate this on
the farm
this is the basic concept
so let's say on a normal year you grow a
pop crop
and your your yield is 50 bushels an
acre all right
you have a canola crop and your yield is
2 000 pounds an acre
okay now you do an inner crop and just
in this example here
let's say you plant
two thirds of your normal field piece
eating rate two-thirds of your normal
canola rates
and you might get
38 bushels instead of 50
and 1400 pounds instead of 2 000 okay
so in this example
this is 100 of a normal pea crop 100 of
a normal canola crop
and down here we've got
of a normal pea crop and 70 of a normal
canola crop
so you add those together
and in this example you would have
a 46
increase in yield
um over either crop alone now that's
pretty hot this is i'm just trying to
use some easier numbers to work with
here
we don't normally see
almost a 50 percent yield increase but
is
uh what i would consider an achievable
target
all right and you don't always get there
either but i think that's something to
shoot for
okay and another way to say this is uh
this is what we would call our ler or
land equivalency ratio
and this example this 50 increase uh we
would write that out as like a 1.46 46
more yield than either crop on its own
okay
all right so uh i just wanted to bring
an example of this here as we go so
what does this mean
so this this is an actual data set that
we had
so we have um this listed as our canola
seeding rate first and then our field
piece seating rate second
so
i didn't list the yields here quite yet
but so we have 100 field pea yield 100
canola yield and this is what it looked
like when we combined them
so when we added canola
we got
a pretty big reduction in our field pea
production okay
but the field peas did not affect our
canola
we saw a maximum of around 25 percent
reduction in our canola yields okay so
you add those two together and we saw
anywhere from a 10 to 23
increase in total yield
now
now for the downfall of the ler it is
not everything right
profits
is what's going to be the most
attractive thing in the system right
so what happens when we actually plug in
the yield
so
uh
the average canola yield this year
was actually
3 400 pounds fantastic canola
our field peas we're only like 35
bushels a maker all right so
we have our ler combined values here
17 16 23 over yielding you say well
those look pretty close
but when you actually puts
the the gross return on not net return
yet when you compute your gross return
we actually see a very big discrepancy
so um up here on the on the upper right
this uh column labeled field p
this would be like if you were growing a
field pea crop
what would happen when you add canola to
it all right
and so because the canola yield was
really good
if we are a field pea grower adding
canola
we're almost always coming out
substantially ahead
because our field pea was only okay and
our canola was fantastic that all right
this column will be if you're a canola
grower and you wanted to add field pizza
that mixture right from that perspective
in this case
uh you're sometimes better off growing
just canola economically all right there
are a few times here this particular
mixture we came out 100 ahead by adding
field piece to our canola because our
canola yield was almost identical
uh to what our monocrop canola yield was
but here this 20 reduction in canola
yield resulted in a big swing
economically here because the field peas
did not make up that difference
based on the price of each crop okay so
ler is interesting it gives us a good
indicator what our system is doing but
economically it might tell a little bit
different story so i just wanted to
bring that up
okay
so
back to chickpea flax
uh why why are we considering chickpea
flex and um you know you notice the
program uh we really have two things
we're talking about field peak canola
chickpea flax right so why
all right for chickpea flax
how we have two very different plant
types right we have chickpeas and flex
and completely different plant families
uh so very different architectures
very different ways they use
nutrients water
different ways that they grow different
architectures they're using sunlight
differently
and when you start talking about
system efficiencies your cropping system
that's a very very big plus in the way
that it's going to be able to utilize
resources okay
doesn't always mean it's going to turn
out in your favor
just at least theoretically this is a
really good thing all right
we've seen some increases in weed
control
i think in some cases we're getting more
yield per acre and um we're going to
talk quite a little bit about um ask a
kite of light coming up because we've
seen some uh really nice things from
that perspective so
we're just kind of pausing mid talk to
briefly give an introduction to ask okay
to play if you're not you're a chickpea
producer you're familiar with it but if
chickpea is new to you you're not so we
just wanted to make sure everyone
was on the same page regarding this
pathogen if you're if you've not grown
chickpea i think it can be a little bit
of a boogeyman you've heard about it it
know it's aggressive it's kind of scary
um but
hopefully by the end of my slides you'll
kind of have an idea if you have an
integrated disease management plan it's
not so bad
well it's bad but you need to you can
manage it all right so it's a fungal
pathogen um you're probably familiar
with ascochyte of light on lentils or
acidopyths
just know that this is a different
pathogen it's specific to chickpea so if
you're adding chickpea into a pea lentil
rotation it's not going to increase your
foliar ascochyta problems and lethal
repeat
it does affect all plant parts so you
can see lesions here on the pods the
stem
and the leaf it forms these kind of
really diagnostic bullseye pattern on
the on the plant and that bullseye those
are little fungal structures and i'll
talk a little bit about that later
it can develop really quickly but you
need kind of wet cool conditions a year
like this year where it was really hot
and really dry does really reduce the
amount of disease that you get
um this is an example this is a
fungicide trial that i had under
irrigation
without this is
no no fungicides um and i'm inoculating
it with chickpea residue that has been
overwintered somewhere so i'm doing
everything i can to get a lot of disease
because that's my job
um and and so if you're not controlling
it it can be quite quite aggressive and
you can end up with complete yield loss
but with this pathogen you know enter we
want to talk about using inner cropping
and just know that's going to be one
part of your management strategy
if if that's what you want to do
so
let's talk about where this pathogen
comes from how it overwinters and how it
spreads within the crop because that's
where the concept of intercropping is
going to come in
so the red circle here that's what's
happening in season
you've got these lesions on your leaf
and we'll talk about how they got there
to begin with but all these little dots
within that lesion these are called
magnetium and they're full of spores
called canadian
and
what's important here is that this is
this is a cycle so these these are going
to germinate and release spores under
wet humid conditions and then rain
and wind are going to spread them around
so the more rain you have the more
spread you get
and this can happen over and over and
over and over again within the growing
season so the more lesions you have the
more canadian you have and the more
spread you have so it's just important
to keep that initial number of lesions
low and get ahead of it
[Music]
all right so
so this is what it's going to be doing
in season
across seasons so you end up with these
stem lesions right you're cutting it
pretty low um so you're going to be
removing some of the pathogen but it's
going out the back of the combine too so
that's going to be your inoculum source
along with the pathogen born on the seed
so if you have contaminated seed
as that seed germinates it can affect
seed germination you're going to end up
with some lesions probably earlier in
the season than you would have otherwise
and again then you start your cycles
earlier which you don't want and then if
that residue is there
that's going to be really the main
provider of inoculum
so all of our management strategies
always have to do with the pathogen
biology and that's why i want you to
understand how this pathogen works
within and across seasons
so our management strategies uh
i talk about ipm a lot just know that's
integrated pest management it just means
throwing everything you can at the
pathogen so we'll start with our
prevention right seed testing seed
treatment and crop rotation and then
spacing out where you're planting your
chickpea fields right if your neighbor
had chickpea last year don't plant
chickpea right next to your neighbor's
chicken that will provide an inoculum
source
and same thing within your own land
uh there is there's documented
literature that increased row spacing
will prevent the spread of that pathogen
in your crop so potentially that's where
the inner cropping comes in you're
increasing your plant spacing but then
you don't have a bunch of bare dirt
where you're not getting any yield
variety selection i'll talk a little bit
about that
you need to be on top of the pathogen
out there scouting for it this is not
like peas or lentils right the
fungicides are going to start when you
see the pathogen right away
you really do have to get ahead of it
and we'll talk about the final sites as
well so this is a stacked approach and
intercropping can definitely be a part
of your approach
all right so if you're new to chickpea
just know that you can get your seed
tested if you're running bin run seed
please test your seed
um 0.3
is your threshold of whether you want to
plant that or not
so don't don't plan chickpea without
testing your seed if you're buying
chickpea seed you should know what your
ascochyta bite levels are
you can send it to the state seed lab in
north dakota or you can send it to the
regional pulse crops diagnostic lab at
montana state um just know it's got
there's going to be a little bit of time
to turn around seven to ten days and no
we can't shorten that because that's how
long it takes for the pathogen to grow
and then um in terms of seed treatment
just make sure you're checking the label
or checking our
uh field
field disease management guide and
making sure it says ascochyto blight and
also pithium pythium is also an
important packaging so just make sure
when you're getting your fungicides you
know those actives
include control of these two pathogens
and it should say
all right so let's talk about variety of
resistance i've color coded these these
are two variety trials i've done over
the past two years
obviously yield has not been optimal in
either of those years and this year
disease levels were really low but even
so we're able to distinguish the very
susceptible chickpea varieties from the
moderately susceptible chickpea
varieties and you definitely want to go
with the latter so here we have we're
comparing cdc
cedar city leader cdc orion sawyer royal
and sierra
there are some different seed sizes in
there so make sure you know what seed
seed side class you're in
andy crown
i don't have on this slide
it is in our
annual report this year for the
williston rec but it kind of fell in
with the leaders in the frontiers so
this is percent severity of ascochyta
blight
the lines in blue kind of cluster
together and the lines in red cluster
together that's just based on
statistical analysis you see disease
severity is higher in the royal and the
sierra and that results in a significant
yield loss
even in a in a year where we have less
disease so making sure you're not
growing a variety that is highly
susceptible
but know that you know in the case of
chickpea production in australia they
did have their disease resistance which
was quite strong in their their chickpea
varieties there overcome
it took about 10 years but their variety
resistance was overcome and that's just
because the pathogen wasn't being
controlled in other ways as well so
that's why i keep harping on stacking
your disease management approach because
there's cases where we don't have that
approach anymore in other countries and
i don't want that to be where we end up
all right so fungicides
there's a lot of old literature out
there that talks about using strabile
urines for the control of ascochyta
blight
resistance was detected kind of in the
mid
2008-2007
in canada it's been documented here in
north dakota so know that you cannot use
cervilians for control of ascopido
blight and shifty they are not effective
the pathogen is resistant
so products where you've got that in the
tank mixed to just know you're not
getting anything from that
um so we're using the factory and the
frac seven a lot of the products are
combo products where they have both of
those groups just if you're applying
more than one application in the season
make sure you're rotating those
and then
michael bunch and i have been working on
tank mixes with chlorothalonil
take maxine chlorothalin with proline
results in really really excellent
disease control right now and the bonus
of that chlorothalinoid is that it's a
multi-site mode of action
and we're helping again control the
pathogen overcoming these products so
that we can have them available to us
for a longer period of time you know so
far we don't have resistance to these
but it's really important that we take
care of these products we're rotating
and we're stacking these other
approaches like intercropping so we
don't get a highly aggressive pathogen
that we can't control
so first timing is going to vary based
on your growing season when do you see
that disease occur in the field just
keep an eye on it
you know if you don't see it up until
flowering your earliest application
could be at early flowering
and then the window is 10 to 14 days
usually in my research trials i'll do
the end of that window the 14 days and
we have a pretty short growing season
some years i've combined chickpeas
mid-august some years but october other
years so it can vary um but
you know if you're on a mid-august
harvest time frame you know you might
end up in a really bad year two to three
applications here in the williston area
but usually um i do around two on my
disease trials i've done up to four
but again that the number of
applications you're gonna make is
dependent on the level of disease in
your field what the weather looks like
you know if you've got a big
thunderstorm coming and you're at the
end of your 14 day window spray ahead of
it right but if weather's hot and dry
maybe you can stretch it out a little
bit just keep an eye on it so it's just
going to be really weather dependent and
again depending on the level of disease
in your field which you've hopefully
minimized through
checking your seed growing a resistant
variety good crop rotation and inner
cropping
all right so mike's going to start us
off with some of the data they've
collected on
the computer
yeah thanks
all right so
um here's some examples of um what we've
been able to
work with with um
that chickpea flax so carrington
just a preface it's not a chickpea
growing region
uh it's never something i would tell
somebody to go yeah you should be
growing chickpeas out here
we do not have an environment for that
we do have a chickpea variety trial but
sometimes i don't know of five fungicide
applications would be enough to
optimally manage
chickpea alone okay
so just throwing that out there
so we do test chickpeas but nobody
really grows them okay in our region
now here we did a trial um over a couple
years
um and williston did a similar one here
with justin jacobs
um we're looking at different chickpea
and flax seeding rates
uh and whether we applied fungicide or
no fungicide now when we applied
fungicide here uh we were this would be
um
two times so two fungicide applications
uh versus none at all
all right
so there's
some things here uh again different
seating rates
uh so
um
here we have the chickpea seating rate
on the left and then the flex seating
rate on the right
and
as we go across our
our table
maybe we'll just start with the
ascochyta information the second column
in the yellow here
so with no fungicide and chickpeas alone
uh we had around uh fifty percent
incidence
in um ascochyta this was measured mid
mid season
um uh
actually two columns so measure twice in
the middle of this season okay
why don't we go to the green one the
green one
i think is a little bit more interesting
yet so
in this case we had 60 incidents uh a
little bit later here in early august
okay
and so now our chickpea alone with two
fungicide applications
we're able to cut that ascochyta
incidence down by about half so about
half the amount of masculine
in our plots all right
now
no fungicide but with different rates of
plaques mixed in with our chickpeas
look at these different
incidences of ascochyta
and you look at those numbers
compared to
chickpea alone with fungicide
so chickpea flax no fungicide at the
bottom
chickpea alone at the top
with fungicide the numbers are very
comparable right
very comparable
all right now we look at the top
fungicide
with inner cropping so essentially
just what uh
audrey was talking about layering so we
have two mechanisms of aspect kind of
control
and we reduce our ascochyta
substantially more
all right
so
fungicide in this case fungicide and
intercropping provided similar amounts
of control you do both
we had an even further reduction than
either
than either control method alone so
uh very fantastic news there now
uh we haven't been able to replicate
quite that same level of efficiency
since then so this isn't something you
should count on
but it's something that may be possible
in some cases okay
so again uh just to throw those numbers
out here a little more simplified if you
uh take the
i have the yields next to it as well the
final yields in both years here so
this year we went from 60 down to
roughly 30
with these two control methods
intercropping and fungicide
and then we reduced it even further with
both now in 2020
uh we saw again um not quite as much as
kakaida with our chickpea alone with no
fungicide
all right
once again we saw a pretty similar
amount of uh reduction whether we were
intercropping or just using fungicides
in our chickpeas
okay but the difference is
uh when we did both fungicide and
intercropping we didn't see that further
step down we saw maybe a slight
reduction in ascochyta with both but it
wasn't nearly as
pronounced as the year before right
now again
um
the uh that's not the end of the story
here all right
this year our flax did really well our
chickpeas didn't do so well and so
with a very aggressive flax crop and
conditions only
you know not very
great for chickpeas
we had huge yield reductions here in our
chickpeas so even though we had these
amazing drop downs in ascochyta control
um this year this might have been
financially feasible but most of the
time flex prices are more normal this
would probably be a bad thing for your
system right
all right
uh 2020 uh we had a much better chickpea
yields
um and flax seals were quite a bit lower
so we still saw a fair amount of
reduction in our chickpea yield
[Music]
not quite as much
so
depending on the prices again
now the one thing we learned is that
when we were doing these trials we
didn't really didn't have low enough
flax rates uh most of the time the flax
was just too competitive with the
chickpeas and we saw
really well i consider a lot of times
unacceptable chickpea yield loss because
most of the time that's going to be the
economic driver right
all right here's a little bit more
balance here where both the chickpeas
did really well and the flax did
actually uh quite well as well so it
wasn't always one way or the other uh in
2018 we had a year where we had
um kind of vote but nonetheless uh
because the flex
we really weren't testing low enough
flax rates in this year either
um and we still
most likely unacceptable yield loss
because if you could market over three
three thousand pounds of chickpea when
you're going on its own
odds are you're gonna be pretty happy
with that so
uh once
again uh
very good for asking title blades um but
i think we need to be really careful at
least in carrington
area with the rate of flex that we're
using
so
to summarize what we've been going
through here
so
in carrington without any control
measures
we might we've been expecting 50 to 60
percent incidence of that circada uh
some years is higher than that this is
what the medium resistor the
one of the
less
susceptible varieties so we have a
little bit of genetic resistance built
in there already too so 50 to 60
incidence of infection
uh we were able to cut that down by
about half to either of these practices
or down to about 75 percent reduction by
stacking and best case scenario okay
all right um
and
i think this was specific to the 2019.
uh our monocrop chickpea
had an 80 reduction in yield without our
fungicide
when we were intercropping our chickpea
we were able to gain thirty percent back
uh with you know without applying any
other fungicides
so
you know there's a
definitely an intrinsic value to having
that inner crop growing
um
there with your chickpeas so
the one thing i didn't show here because
it's a pretty boring graph but
uh we actually saw 100 control of white
mold in the one year that we had a big
white mold outbreak in our chickpeas
we had any amount of flex in the plot we
had zero white mold if we had just
chickpeas we had substantial white mold
okay
so it's a pretty boring graph but
uh and then of course my biggest
takeaway is that
um i think
in our area 10 pounds an acre of blacks
is the most i would consider ever
putting in the system okay
maybe we need to go even less than that
and uh i think
turn it over to claire at this point
alrighty hello everybody um
claire keane
and
sorry that i'm not there in person um
hopefully some of you recognize me from
out in my from my time out in williston
um
been here in fargo the last few months
and
still adjusting to the new job but very
happy to be able to share with you some
data from williston
okay so i'm going to talk about two
trials uh that i conducted in 2018 and
2020 at the williston research extension
center dryland farm
so these were not done under irrigation
and um i think
that was a nice transition from mike um
in those
seating rates of flax because what was i
i was interested
um you know
oh gosh three years ago now um when
starting to do this is you know could i
identify
a flax seeding rate that reduced the
ascochyta blight
without reducing chickpea yields so that
was my goal
in both years i used cdc orion chickpea
which is a kabuli type and then cdc
glass flax
and uh the
treatments that i used i guess i'll can
you see the mouse if i move it on the
screen
yep you're good okay great so i i had my
uh treatments
ranging from monocrop chickpea to
chickpea with five pounds of flax 10 15
20 40 pounds of flax and then a monocrop
flax of 40 pounds per acre is a check um
in percents my kid presented um his data
in terms of a percent of that full
seating rate so five pounds of flax
compared to 40 pounds is 12 and a half
percent so this is 12 and a half percent
of the mono crop
37 and a half percent 50
and 100
so just to give you
um
that continuity there so i did have some
of these lower rates included in my
trials
i also wanted to point out planting
configurations and this will
this will have implications when we get
into the yield
but i did use different planters in the
two years of these studies
so in 2018 we used an old single row
planter with 10 inch spacing and on that
single row planter there's a different
funnel essentially for each row and so i
would dump you know packet of flax
packet of chickpea packet of flax packet
of chickpea um in the inner crop plots
or just all chickpea or flax envelopes
um for the mono crops so what that ended
up looking like
was a four row plot of chickpea with
monocrop
uh as i mentioned flax chickpea flax
with the inner crop plot and then mono
crop flax
all flax
and that seeding rate of the monocrop
chickpea was about 120 pounds per acre i
was targeting that four plants uh per
foot of rose so seeding it at about four
to five seeds per foot
um
i didn't uh something that it kind of
dawned on me like after i planted the
trial this did result in half as many
chickpea plants present
in the inner crop plots as the monocrop
because i didn't double that seeding
rate of chickpea in the inner crop so
functionally the seeding rate in my 2018
trial was 120 pounds per acre of
chickpea
in the mono crop but then 60 pounds per
acre of chickpea with those different
rates of flax in the inner crop and then
the mono crop at 40 pounds
and so just a picture of that um you can
see flax chickpea flax chickpea so that
four row plot and alternating rose
in 2020 we used a cone cedar and that
cone seeder
like we used in many of our variety
trials
is designed to be able to do um you know
different varieties of the same crop
plot to plot and so it's
a six row cedar with eight inch spacing
so
looking at the mono crop flax that's
what normally gets planted out of this
planter is um you have your seeding rate
and you just put it down the cone cedar
and away you go
but to do the chickpea we actually put
it in the fertilizer box so the chickpea
was coming out of the banded fertilizer
tubes
and so my mono crop chickpea plots were
three rows of chickpea
at a 15 inch spacing
the inner crops
that chickpea was still coming out in
that 15 inch spacing but then the 8 inch
spacing of the flax rose on top of it
and then again that mono crop flax was
six rows of flax at an eight inch
spacing
the mono crop chickpea rate was 120
pounds per acre again
but because of this different planter
configuration i was able to keep the
chickpea seeding rate consistent between
the mono crop and the inner crops in
2020 and again
you know when we get to yield i think
there's something interesting there to
mention with
that so 2020 a picture of those plots um
there's an outer row of flax a row of
chickpea
two rows of flax between the next row of
chickpea again two rows of flax chickpea
and then an outer row of flax so
different configurations between 2018
and 2020.
so for effects on ascochytoblite in 2018
um
again just remembering that there were
half as many chickpea plants in the
inner crops as the mono crop
um i looked at incidents as the number
of chickpea plants out of 10 with
ascochyto blight lesions present so just
presence or absence from 10 plants
randomly selected in the plot
and then severity used a 0 to 10 scale
oh sorry about that
with no lesions
being zero and a rating of 10 meaning
many lesions present throughout the
canopy including on upper leaves and
pods
and so in 2018
there were significant differences in
ascochyta incidents
at the july 17 sampling date where mono
crop chickpea had higher incidence than
intercropping with chickpea and flax
but noting that even though it was
statistically similar
that monocrop chickpea into the vasco
kaido was higher than all of the
inner crop combinations
and on july 31st the severity rating
again
with severity being on a 0 to 10 scale
that mono crop chickpea plot was rated
at a
rated at 7.3
uh which was
significantly different from
any of the inner crop rates of 10
15 20 and 40 pounds of flax and then
that five pounds of flax being similar
to both the mono crop and those higher
rates of flax
and so there wasn't um you know
obviously a statistical difference at
every sampling date
but i do know that
you know even with um severity and
incidents of july 17th and 31st again
that trend of the monocrop chickpea
having the highest rating
both in terms of
severity and incidents is there
and now 2018 um was a pretty wet year
for us out at the williston rec
um we had approximately 9.2 inches of
rain between may and august so certainly
one of the better rainfall years we've
had
in the last last five
and then
we did spray the whole trial with
fungicide twice so on june 25th and july
12th so all of these treatments did have
two applications of foliar fungicides
now in 2020 so again just reminding you
that there's the same density of
chickpea plants in the mono crop and the
inner crop in this year
i also change my scales um with some
input from plant pathologists thank you
audrey uh number of chickpea plants out
of 20 with ascochyta lesions present so
again that presence absence um and then
the severity of a one nine one to nine
scale i learned that that's a more
typical scale in uh plant pathology so
we went with that
so one meaning no lesions and nine again
many lesions present
throughout the canopy and then also with
wilting or dead plants present
and so in 2020 we did these ratings july
1 july 9 july 24
and the only time we saw a statistically
significant difference was july 24
where on the incidents 15 approximately
15 out of 20 chickpea plants checked um
had ascochytal lesions present uh which
was different from with 10 pounds of
flax
roughly 11 and 11 plants with that um
20 pounds of flax
um so not a lot of statistical
differences in 2020 however again that
trend so on july 1st
of
more plants and the monocrop chickpea
plots having ascochyta present then the
inner crop plots that that was true at
july 1
and july 9
and then severity
these severity ratings just were not
very high in 2020 which makes sense in
light of the the drought that we had so
still that trend of the monocrop
chickpea having a more um
you know more severe nature of that
infestation but again relative to 2018
these are pretty low numbers um i'll
just go back quick you know so reminder
in 2018 looking at a 10 plants
by the end of july even with two
fungicide applications i was seeing
those monocrop uh plots
you know 10 out of 10 plants having
ascochyta present
um
but then you go to 2020 and out of 20
plants you know 15 out of 20 in the mono
crop
and down around you know 11
out of 20 plants in the higher rates of
flax center crops so very different
years in terms of moisture
but i think that that still shows that
one in a dry year you can still have
ascochyta
but then two inner cropping while it may
not provide as as high degree as of
control is in a wetter year
it's still doing something
and again just pointing out so in 2020
the growing season rainfall was
approximately 4.3 inches so half half of
what it was in 2018 and again this whole
trial did receive fungicide
three times in 2020.
um it's something uh
mike mentioned in his preface that
intercropping might increase the need
for desiccation and i do think that's
true especially with the p
uh canola combination that'll get talked
about later
but just kind of an interesting side
note um in my conversations with lena
shaw and some other growers in canada
you know they had noticed that they felt
that intercropping chickpea and flax
generally provided a benefit to chickpea
dry down that that chickpea or sorry
having the flax with the chickpea just
encourage the chickpea to um to shut
down you know late summer like you want
it to and start drying down rather than
staying green and continuing to flower
and so i did dry down ratings each year
and so in 2018
went out about every 10 days and rated
the plots for the percent of chickpea
plants with mature color
and there were significant differences
at each of those dates again this was in
a pretty wet year
and then in 2020 that dry down happens
with the drought
certainly much more quickly
um
but again
the the trend of those intercropped uh
plots drawing down the chickpea faster
uh really held true and i feel like to
me and an interesting um
observation in 2018 again um a pretty
wet growing season you know you start to
see the spread really widen you know
functionally the difference between zero
percent of your chickpea plants with
mature color on august 2nd
and um hope i keep losing my cursor
there we go and five percent um
you know doesn't doesn't mean anything
right and then the difference between 15
and 30
you know that spread starting to widen
but then by the time we get to august
24th um seeing you know pure chickpea
and chickpea with five pounds of flax
down at this 60 65 mature color um but
the chickpea with 20 and 40 pounds up at
80 percent that's a pretty big
difference you know that might be
close to that tipping point of if you
were going to go out and desiccate um to
do that and be able to harvest those
chickpeas potentially a week or two
earlier
than you otherwise might have
i think is really important
um and then in 2020 just with that very
dry summer
um you know that
chickpea was drying down much more
quickly august 4th we were already at 30
percent mature color and the mono crop
um compared to about 56
with the 40 pounds of flax uh so just
that inner cropping does seem to push
push that
chickpea dry down uh more quickly and
again you know maybe at the production
scale i'd say we don't we don't have
good data on that yet um but if this is
a way that a grower could get into that
field earlier to harvest those chickpeas
prevent it from getting rained on next
week or two weeks from now i think
that's where there's there's some real
potential with this
uh for some photos so these are from
august 14th of 2018. so monocrop
chickpea here on the left um and i'll
just point out so there's still quite a
few you know dark green healthy leaves
doing doing photosynthesis and if you
see a dead plant or you know what you
might think of this mature color in that
mono crop plant
i would say in nine out of ten cases
those plants aren't mature color because
they naturally senesce it's because
ascochyta
killed them
you know a week or more ago and so
that's what you're seeing in the
monocrop chickpea plants when you see
brown
with the 10 pounds of flax so those
chickpea rose are here and here
and then chickpea with 40 pounds of flax
on the far right um those chickpea
plants just have many fewer lush green
leaves they're much more yellow and so
that's what i was capturing with those
ratings on the earlier slide
from 2020 again with a drought year um
august 4th so
chickpea is definitely drying down more
quickly in 2020 than they did in 2018
but again just looking at those mono
crop chickpea rose more green present
there
with five pounds of flax those chickpea
rose are starting to get lost in the
yellow flax and then at that 20 pound
rate of flax
i'd say the chickpea leaves are getting
pretty hard to pick out from the
um
flax stems as they're all
turning yellow pretty quickly
um this is a photo taken at harvest of
so again these are small plots
i did not need to desiccate in either
2018 or 2020 to be able to harvest these
so after that last set of ratings we
waited another five days or so
and went out and with the small plot
combine it worked there really wasn't
much green material it was pretty clean
in terms of weeds
we did use spartan ahead of planting
and that did a nice job in these fields
so
weeds certainly if you have green weeds
out there that could be an issue that
needs desiccation
and i'd say you know it's
certainly too soon to say whether you
can get away with desi without
desiccation in the system um but there
might be years in which that's possible
um but again something to to play with
at a field scale if you're a grower
considering this
here's a shot of my inner crop straight
out of the combine
it to me i mean it did look pretty good
certainly we had a lot of pieces of
chickpea pods and straw
but those separated out very easily with
the the clipper cleaners that we have at
the wrec
so now in terms of yields
so in 2018
we
i did not see over yielding in any year
so just to put that out there
um but i do think there were some
interesting things happening
with um
the with both the chickpeas and the flax
and these different yields so in 2018
um the monocrop chickpea did yield the
most um the most chickpea of all the
treatments uh but then certainly the
most total poundage of
of grain coming out of the field
so the different letters on these uh
light beige bars indicate
statistical differences in the chickpea
yield
so monocrop chickpea
5 10 and 15 pounds of flax it did step
down from the monocrop chickpea we went
from about 1700 pounds
per acre down to about 1100 pounds um
but that was statistically similar to
the monocrop
but then also the lower yields of
chickpea
when it was intercropped with 20 and 40
pounds of flax and so down there it was
roughly 850 and 620 pounds of chickpea
at these higher inner crops
and we did see the flax
yields stay kind of similar
at those lower rates of intercropping
but then step up at the higher seeding
rates
and something again just to remind you
about like that planting configuration
um i didn't have plant stand counts
unfortunately so i don't i don't know
the mechanism at play here but i do
think it's interesting that even though
we had half as many chickpea plants in
these inner crops because they're just
two rows of chickpea compared to four
rows over here
we were getting about two thirds of the
chickpea yield as the monocrop so we're
getting two thirds the yield with half
the seeding rate
so i you know
had i had the uh foresight back in 2018
when i was planning this to put in
the other set of plots with the same
number of chickpea plants in those two
rows um i'm really curious to know what
that would have done but but i think
that shows maybe there's some potential
for over yielding you know at the plant
level potentially maybe with that lower
density of chickpea there they responded
by um getting bigger producing more pods
you know but i didn't collect that data
so i'm not sure
um in 2020 so looking at 2020 um
definitely
saw the potential for flax to be much
more competitive in a dry year than a
white year i think that's the take home
of 2020. so overall our yields were
lower the monocrop chickpea yielded just
a little bit over a thousand pounds per
acre and then it did step down
as the flax seeding rate increased so
even five pounds per acre of flax uh did
decrease it to about 700 pounds of
chickpea
um
and so
so there i think the take home message
is if we're in a real dry situation even
a very low rate of flax can reduce
chickpea yield
but then just you know looking at maybe
the bright side and certainly a bright
side and a year where flax is worth 30
bushel um the flax did really really
well i had to you know kind of do a
double take when i when i was thinking
about it but so our mono crop flax
between 2018 and 2020 um 780 pounds in a
year with nine inches of rain
oh sorry um about 800 800 pounds per
acre um in a mono crop flax with nine
inches of rain in the growing season
uh compared to 780 pounds so very very
comparable
and
excuse me and then that flax again just
showing its
drought
hardiness really um stepping up in yield
uh as its seeding rate was increased and
i just noted that between the chickpea
intercropped with flax at the 40 pound
rate
between 2018 and 2020 um really just
kind of flip-flopped which i thought was
interesting
so
okay and so i'll wrap it up here um so
for the optimal seating rate of flax
that question you know did we find
something that can reduce ascochyto
blight but then also maintain chickpea
yield
i think that 10 to 15 pounds of flax
appears to be kind of that sweet spot to
balance
reducing ascochyta pressure with
maintaining chickpea yield however in a
dry year that could certainly um reduce
the chickpea yield
five pounds of flax wasn't enough to
consistently reduce ascochyta while 20
pounds did consistently reduce chickpea
compared to the monocrop
the rate of chickpea dry down if that's
something you're interested in did seem
to be a little bit more consistent the
15 pound rate of flax and higher
but we do need growers to test if this
holds true at a production scale
and then
finally you know again flax is much more
competitive with chickpea in a dry year
so just something certainly in the
western part of the state or eastern
montana uh we need to keep in mind if um
if that's what the growing season is is
like
uh so with that um we will
um take any questions you have uh myself
mike and audrey are all available for
your questions well claire i'll kick it
off with a ques question on my own if
you don't mind
so
if i'm interpreting this correctly in
the
2018 trials the row spacing between
chickpea
um
was all the same
you know across your your inter crop and
mono crop but in
but in 2020 your your row spacing in
your monocrop
was greater right you have you had an
increased row spacing
do you think that that could have played
a role in the reduction in disease you
saw
and the less the the reduced difference
you saw essentially between that
monocrop and the inner crop given that
you did have a wide row spacing in your
monocrop jv
right right so there were 15 inches
between chickpea
rose and 20 20 where there whereas there
was only 10 inches between rows and 2018
but then also i'd say two confounding
factors
two rows of flax between those two rows
of chickpea in 2020 versus only one row
of flax between the rows of chickpea in
and then throw on top of it just a much
hotter and drier growing season
um so i think back to your question yes
that wider row spacing um
could could be one of the factors why
just overall severity incidence severity
and incidence ratings were less
in 2020 than 2018.
um
you know but
but i guess i don't i don't have a real
confidence in whether i would attribute
the overall lower ratings to that
different planting configuration or just
to that much drier
uh growing growing season
yeah i'm just thinking maybe you would
have seen a bigger difference between
the treatments in 2020 if you have been
on like an eight inch row spacing for
the mono crop compared to
those chickpea flax chickpea blocks and
eight inches
true either way you said that's
interesting okay so we've got a question
looks like in the chat
could you talk about any potential
benefits or disadvantages to planting
and alternating roads versus planting
both crops together in the same row
i did
however you want to take that
and i think uh later on atlanta uh shaw
has some information that will help with
that too but i think claire you had some
you had a more of a comparison for this
didn't you
i had tried um
so it ended up being a trial that didn't
work out in 2018
i also tried planting some long strips
of chickpea and flax in either
same rows or alternating rows um
actually right next door to those plots
that you saw pictures of
um
to
with the goal of tracking ascochyta over
the season and seeing if the mecstro
versus the
alternating rows made a difference
and unfortunately we planted that
might have been a week to 10 days later
i don't really recall
but
we had let's see 2018. yeah we
2018 my planting conditions were really
ideal um
that single row planter is not very
heavy and doesn't really have
good depth control so when we planted
the
the trial that you saw data from it all
went in the ground nicely and germinated
nicely and we had good stands but those
mixture versus alternating rows that we
planted next door
going just a week or ten days later the
surface had dried out enough
that the chickpea just didn't get deep
enough and so there was a very poor
chickpea stand there
and i ended up not not collecting data
on it
i think
sorry for rambling but i think i'll
probably defer to elena who has better
data on that um just to my
limited observation in 2018 um
i don't recall
um
is pronounced differences in ascochyta
between say mono crop chickpea and um
the inner cropped
or sorry
monocrop chickpea versus
uh
chickpea and flax either in the same row
or alternating row in those
uh strips that i put out
but
my issue there is there were just very
few chickpea plants in in both places so
i don't really have a good read on that
um my sense is that alternating rose
would have an advantage for ascochyta
control
again knowing that that row spacing and
you know if we're
uh
yeah that row spacing can have an impact
on ascochyta incidents in monocrop
chickpea than i would expect if you can
have
essentially an architecture where you're
putting lots of barriers between
chickpea plants so in the case of my
2020 trial where you have row of
chickpea two rows of flax row of
chickpeas two rows of flax
certainly you know in that same chickpea
row there's there's contact between
leaves but you're putting barriers there
side to side that would help limit
physical spread
but i'll i'll certainly um deferred
elena because i think she's um played
with that more more than i have
and i will say you know it is a
trade-off because
um you know again when you're doing
these intercrop tickets you're usually
picking two crops that have very
different seed sizes and so you know of
course the big advantage of alternating
is that you can set each row to plant
the crop exactly where it likes to be
planted when you do a mixed rule
you have to
do something in between
in most cases and so you're usually
planting your small seeded crop deeper
than you normally plant
your big seeded crops shallower than
your normal implants
so the conditions have to be
a little more sensitive when you're
doing the mixed roll
yeah and mike um there's another
question in the chat that's a good
follow-up to that
a question for mike since you seated in
the same row did you go at the full
chickpea seating depth or shallow up
somewhere in between
so yeah when we do our chickpea flax um
i think we usually target about an inch
and a quarter
um and then
when we do our field peak canola we
usually put it right around an inch or
maybe just slightly more
and you know usually we've found that
the smaller seeded crop comes up easier
if it's in the mixture because
you know it does have that large seeded
crop to help it get out of the ground so
you do have some synergy there
but
you know
if you're worried about the moisture
conditions though
um
you know and you have different things
to plant i would definitely be planting
your mixtural inner crop at the right
timing for what your soil moisture is
i would say that much at least